Hello, this video explains the topic of
missing values. It is important to pay attention
to missing or invalid values ​​when creating and interpreting tables. In
survey research, there are
usually missing values ​​where there is no answer
. I can't say or I don't know
was answered so that the statistics are
not falsified by missing values
the percentage and the valid percentage should be
specified in the frequency table how do I calculate
the valid percentage now the absolute
frequencies of a characteristic are divided by
the valid cases don't worry
i'll show you that now  to be more precise, with
an example let's say we asked 30 people
what their favorite
car's fault was five people
answered fort seven people
answered i can't say and the
rest indicated the car brands now
we want to calculate what percentage they
entered on site
that works  of course very simple  ch for
this we simply take the five people
who have given from now on and divide it by
the 30 people we
have interviewed so 5 by 30
equals 16.7 so that we can now calculate the valid percentage
we simply have to
omit the seven people who
gave  I can't say anything
so the calculation is as
follows we have our
five people down here but now we
only have 23 people because the seven people
who have ticked I can't say anything are missing
accordingly we have five divided by 23
and we get 21.7  percent so the
valid percent is 21.7 and the
normal percent is 16.7 and now
i will show you how you can
easily create a frequency table online for
this please go to cap de
click on the statistics calculator and
then when you enter your
want to use your own data click on
teach table
i have a small example here,
just copy it and k  copy it in
this table
here we see the students and what
their favorite car brand is
we would now like to have a frequency table for the
car brand let's go to
descriptive statistics and
simply drink the car brand
now we already see the
frequency table below
we can also select  that
we would like to have the percent and the valid
percent and now
here we get the
frequency table for the car brand very simply below we
see three people have ticked
vw three people have ticked skoda
two people bmw and two people opel
and one person daimler one value  is
invalid which we see here
it is so easy to create a
frequency table with datatec do
you want to know what a crosstab
is and how to create it
watch the video on the left
do you want to know how to do
further analyzes with delta tab
just watch the video on
the right  te on and
see you next time